nous on voit tout on voit on voit qu'un
jour on sera plus là on veut qu on veut
que notre enfant soit autonome on veut
que l'on annonçait on sait ce que ça lui
prendrait puis on s'attendrait à ce que
l'école nous donne mais l'écologiste
pour les moyens de le donner
est ce que c'est normal que l'école n'a
pas les moyens de le donner je sais pas
si une base de questions je sais pas
souvent je me dis je regarde tout ce que
fait la commission scolaire elle en fait
beaucoup
puis des fois je m'interroge me dit elle
est où la limite de à partir de quand à
partie quand l'école est plus dans sa
mission je ne sais pas je n'ai pas la
réponse je vous le dis je l' ai pas la
réponse mais je vois qu'il ya des choses
on donne beaucoup de choses est ce que
ces données de façon optimale peut-être
pas toujours je sais que la commission
scolaire réfléchit beaucoup à ces
pratiques
ça évolue en permanence c'est vrai c'est
sûrement pas suffisant puis on a découpé
normes du ministère qui font qu'on est
là il faut qu'on fasse de plus en plus
avec de moins en moins mais on atteint
des parents dont les enfants sont
diagnostiqués qu'ils sont déprimés
non je pense eux-mêmes a suscité en
développement qui sont sur les
antidépresseurs qui disent que leur vie
est un calvaire et une bataille
est-ce que ça c'est normal non ça c'est
pas normal ça c'est pas normal mais je
vous dirais que là la réflexion qu'on a
à voir aller au delà de l'école c'est
vraiment un problème de société
parce que comme je vous dis le problème
commence quasiment à la naissance de
l'enfant puis l'enfant il est le parent
il n'est pas accompagné comme il devrait
l'être ça c'est une certitude